the media's favorite way to report a
story is from their prison of two ideas
where they are lifers and that two idea
cell you're either pro-immigration or a
xenophobic bigot you either love this
planet or embrace evil big oil you're
either for peace or you want war their
latest you either shut down the economy
and definitely or you want people to die
that preposterous filter makes it easy
for them to slam the other side it
absolves them of nuanced intelligence
and thoughtfulness which are completely
missing here he's a fan of money first
mortality second The Greatest Generation
they're going to be sacrificed for what
fear that Trump's efforts to be
President will be hurt he's going to
fast causing confusion and quite
possibly endangering lives in the
process stay in and for the president to
make light of that as if it's like well
so what some people will die but the
economy will grow no the president who's
eager to try to get the economy back on
track because he sees it as wedded to
his chances of being reelected the
president is putting human life at risk
it's literally immoral literally who is
she now do they really believe Trump is
putting the economy before human life no
it's just a game these idiots play to
keep busy
fact is solutions to problems aren't
either/or but this and that the solution
here will be flexible and ever-changing
depending on the risks as we identify
them so it may be that we return to work
in phases young and healthy first
perhaps depending on region and type of
business there are lots of factors and
also reasons for guarded optimism
it's ÿþ out she and Trump work well
together
ouchies the cautious voice Trump is the
generator of hope understanding that
people crave deadlines even if those
deadlines change the press forgets that
when it's bad cop good cop both cops
want the same outcome what would the
media prefer Trump to say it doesn't
matter at all since they're often wrong
but a smart person can stand back and
see the whole field the
just stares at one patch of the ground
and screams at the ants you know Dana I
think that like Trump understands that
people need a measure of certainty and
the certainty comes in a date even
though the date is going to change the
idea that you could see a light at the
end of the tunnel is a way that you
could be optimistic and and get through
the next week or two weeks people smart
people understand this yeah so
permission to make an analogy mm-hmm
what okay so I have permission
permission granted John was doing it in
my ear
sorry Oh Shawn okay so my analogy is
this if you've ever worked out with a
trainer yes
let's say they tell you you're going to
do 15 squats 3 sets of 15 and you finish
that that and then they say all right
one more set of 15 right what but you
know what you do it because it's good
for you yes and you get through it
and so I sort of think about this like
can I make it to Easter yeah and I make
it easy yes
I can make it easier now if at that
point they say you know what we got to
do one more week yeah
ok I can do one more week it's good for
me and I think that your to your point
this will be done thoughtfully there's
nothing rash going on except for maybe
throwing 25 million dollars to the
Kennedy Center - yes yeah what is it
fair to say that like the president take
would choose an economy over the death
of its citizens well I hope not I mean I
just don't think that what we should be
saying about President Trump or anybody
man we got to understand it but to my
mind you know this is what I was trying
to say yesterday I think there's a
disconnect even if you try to look at
the President as an optimist the
cheerleader for all of us there's a
disconnect between what he's saying and
what we're hearing from the scientists
and from the doctors including dr.
Falchi with regard to when we could
realistically expect to lift this
because if we rush this Greg and say
let's get back to work by Easter then we
could incur a second wave of this kind
of coronavirus outbreak and get that you
know the famous curve could you know
spike again and we don't want that
because that's not good for the economy
and it's certainly not good for people
who are at high risk you know grandma
and granddad right even me
yes so we want to we want to keep me
alive I want to keep I want you to get
you back to work and it's just the
president thank you thank you but I just
think that you know to say to blame the
president I think it's to say mr.
president please pay attention
there's nobody in our society that we
should be riding off but we even if
you're just thinking about the economy
keep in mind what the doctors and
scientists are saying we need to be able
to rely on you as a trustworthy source
and right now people are not so much
interested in the kind of cheerleading
as they want to know exactly what we're
up against but what are we being
required to do that will help us but
Jesse it seems that that the public do
trust President Trump on this and the
optimism is valuable when it's paired to
say the sober analysis of the expert
voci that's why they're together the
good cop bad cop
I know Juan hates polls but the polls
say the public trust Trump over the
media don't mean to rub it in it's just
a fact one someone just sent me a great
line are you guys ready for this yes if
you tell people that if you have to stay
inside for seven days straight in order
to save the twenty20 football season the
entire South would be locked in their
room right now do it for football do it
do it for football all right so that's
how you got to get it across the people
and I agree with Greg it's a it's a
false dichotomy
you're not saying let's open up business
in order to pay Wall Street bonuses
that's not what you're doing you're not
trying to say let's kill grandma so Wall
Street fat cats can get rich that's not
what they're saying they're saying we're
gonna look at the science the data and
the models not the models that Juan
likes that the models with the graphs I
that's going to determine if Easter is
the right date or we have to extend it
another week like Dana's trainer makes
her that doesn't that doesn't mean
you're killing people so we get a higher
GDP that just means you're working smart
you're working safely because a lot of
Americans outside of New York feel like
they'll take my chance with coronavirus
but I'm not going to take my chance with
a Great Depression yeah you know and a
lot of people that get coronavirus don't
die that's not saying it's not a threat
that's not saying it's not a risk but
people see risks in other measures and
that's what you're trying to balance
Katie last word what do you think right
hey Greg before you go can I make a
quick point oh wait let me just get
Katie in one Oh prediction on the on the
media narrative here so when he does
start opening up the economy incremental
he's not just gonna open up everything
right away right they're gonna complain
about the border to Mexico not being
opened up fast enough for example
they're gonna say that the Chinese
should be able to fly back and forth but
the Europeans should also be able to fly
back and forth we doesn't open up those
things fast enough but the stimulus bill
that they're trying to get done in DC
right now as we speak will buy them time
so that the medical experts have more
time to convince the public and to ask
them as they have been doing to follow
the guidelines we can get out of this
thing and then President Trump will be
able to make some economic moves there
are places in the country that will not
you know we'll have well there will be
longer implications for this like New
York like California but the idea that
Democrats don't like this in the media
don't like it either because President
Trump is speaking to the workers that
they are supposed to be in charge of
that they are supposed to be in control
of politically president Trump has
always spoken to the workers he's always
had a populist message and that is the
same today and that's why they're having
a visceral reaction to this so that's
exactly who is talking to well can I
don't say I hope that he's looking out
for workers and their families but I
just wanted to make a quick point about
the arteries and even about the green
New Deal that you guys keep harping on
you know there are a lot of people going
back to the o8 where you saw people say
we gotta save America's arts and
cultures because there are millions of
jobs related to arts and culture like
Spore
and there's millions of jobs in
renewable and well while there's not
there's a lot more jobs in restaurants
and honey eyetality at the Kennedy
Center
all right their jobs there yeah but I'm
saying 25 million right you know what I
see watts point but I for one am NOT
gonna miss performance art okay that
doesn't come back I will live